action in the public needs to know news
tell us you know submitted by IKEA
meatballs plane inspectors are
whistleblowing on the FAA saying they're
pressured to ignore critical plane
problems oh no oh my god that's no
[ __ ] scam I have been flying so much
lately that is not something I want to
hear but like it's still safer than
riding a bicycle or driving a car that's
true like statistically yeah yeah by far
well how many accidents do you see
versus plane accidents that you hear
when I'm on a bike I haven't gotten out
and they're like the last 15 20 now how
many times you ride a bike so these
inspectors are whistleblowing they're
saying that recently they have changed
their way that they're doing things and
now it's getting scarier because in the
past yes it's been like [ __ ] safe
like their statistics are amazing would
they change that you know why money
they're not making money anymore
so this is what's happening these two
Federal Aviation Administration
inspectors they've talked to CBS News
and they were saying that the flying
public needs to know and needs to wake
up yes
and know that this is not as safe as it
could be or as it used to be and so
they're saying that they have so many
times have been told like look the other
way if they find like corrosion on a
plane or something wrong with it an
airlines plane like the fleet that they
will actually get assigned to a
different airline just so they don't
have to deal with that one airline
that's not nice
yes and so it used to be super safe yeah
and so they're saying that airlines are
viewed as the clients of the FAA like
that's the the problem here but they're
they're not viewing that they don't want
to lose the clients yeah I say and so
they're not viewing the public as a top
priority its airlines interests top
priority oh and that's what's the scary
thing that's happening here but where
would the airlines go like if they have
to get regulated like where else would
they even go they don't kind of have a
monopoly on that I mean just kind of
logically hearing
this I'm just like well wouldn't like as
soon as accidents start happening back
to back to back like I'm pretty sure
Airlines I like well we don't ever want
that to happen so maybe they do enough
cutting corners where it's like it's
still relatively safe where they're not
their [ __ ] airplanes aren't crashing
and disappearing
yeah but recently there have been more
crashes oh [ __ ] commercial commercial Oh
or no well one of them so Miami air
International it has a charter service
with about a thousand government
contracts worth more than 200 million
dollars in just the past five years and
earlier this month one of their charters
that was carrying US military troops
from Guantanamo Bay Cuba it had a crash
landing in Jacksonville Florida luckily
no one died but they're saying that the
cause is not yet known and they're just
saying like this wasn't the first time I
like how they put this in the story but
like they don't even know what the crash
was so it's not even it might not even
be related to the article but they're
like you see it could be master trains
man we just need a bullet train that's
all we [ __ ] need I love the bullet
train oh why can't they make that well
that was because it wasn't safe to in
America yeah that's why I got that's why
they don't have but they got so many all
over the world and it's Underground in
America I watched his video on why
didn't work out here it's because the
distance that we have before it's yeah
our country is just too big and our
cities are too wide apart or it would
make more sense if our cities were much
closer like Japan and then yeah I like
the Elliott a San Francisco one that
they stopped I know other than that I
heard it was a auto conspiracy like the
auto no San Diego duh yeah it was like
supposed to be the entire code other
than cool and then they chopped it I
forgot where but now it's like this tiny
little section instead of the whole
thing that one's a weird one because
they actually got a lot of funding and
then the money disappeared yeah votes
not voted for it voted for it yeah so
they got like billions of dollars and it
just disappeared mm-hmm and then there
was no movement so everyone's like
there's a there's a conspirator where
the [ __ ] did it go
I mean it would have been nice for our
rows cuz we got some [ __ ] up roads in
California that's what I'm saying we
have the highest
taxes in the most [ __ ] up roads for a
blue stare [ __ ] do those taxes go our
schools our [ __ ] our roads our [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] do those taxes go that's
what happens in a democratic state so
what I'm saying I want a fast [ __ ]
train if that was the case I should you
know I probably still be living in
Sacramento I just come down here I will
just take an hour [ __ ] train right
here yeah and you work 11:00 Davis
yes well we train to Vegas try to work
on that what happened let me try to work
on that to just money running out or
they could just make better [ __ ]
trains right now and I would like them
to be tears right so you have the
regular one and the one that's weight a
little more expensive that we could pay
for because the [ __ ] office look a
little dirty a little bit you see a
regular ones people pull their penises
off no there's like a Joe comment no if
they do the regular Metro there's
someone playing a guitar and someone
pulling their penis out all the time
they have luxury trains though where you
can it's almost like a hotel room yeah
intercontinental [ __ ] that [ __ ] takes
like oh [ __ ] week just to get to like
Mexico or something forever
I want one from like Santa Monica to
downtown that'd be cool like in 20 30
minutes without tonight without some
upon their dick oh yeah a drag I've been
to it
no but they pull their dick out is what
he's Sam cuz Amtrak's on a commuter
plane that's like a straight-up
transportation I'm talking like the
Metro like something that people could
take every day to and from work you have
a subway yeah bad but when Muriel and I
took the train to Santa Monica it there
was a man and he was a homeless man but
everybody had to leave that cab because
he smelled so [ __ ] bad like nobody
could breathe now somehow I was trying
to be a good guy just [ __ ] suck it up
a mojito smell you don't smell you know
he I was like I can't do this like I
lasted like maybe a second and I let it
go to the other one there was a man on
my flight back that smell like diarrhea
yeah and I looked back in and it was
like Japanese grandma and her son and
then they were looking at each other
like they just saw death and it when he
went up to go I was like man I wonder if
he's gonna go change his pants cuz I
think he [ __ ] himself mmm did he I don't
know
when he came back he still smelled like
[ __ ] but it seats probably yeah not be
able to stand it I would throw up on the
spot it would just melt like barf and
[ __ ] yeah but I really want to happen is
that one the rocket ship one where you
take a rocket you could go anywhere in
the world in less than an hour that's
the one I wanted to happen less than an
hour I forgot but I feel like it was
Ilan my idea it is yeah right how much
is it ticket for something like that
everybody was trying to be less than of
airplane - yeah yes did you know that we
we should be a hundred years ahead in
technology but the government's holding
that [ __ ] back I believe that what do
you think they they have hidden from us
right now we have alien technology that
they copied when the aliens crash at
Roswell they learned how to make it on
themselves and then Hitler was working
with the Nazis on how to develop
anti-gravity device and then there's
pictures of him with UFOs and stuff and
then when those scientists came to
America they taught our scientists how
to make it and so we actually have UFOs
already what's the guy's name
that's guy that Steven watch monitors
are used to engineer the UFOs
interesting stuff huh I mean we don't
need a train we could just use
teleportation it would be nice to just
at least start with all the training we
have you I thought that I mean we that
should be easy I just don't want to
drive ever I hate driving well they're
working on self-driving cars I feel like
that's gonna happen in the next five
years like my baby because that Tesla's
he is already halfway there yeah so for
sure if there's a car that doesn't this
just drives completely I'm fine
cuz then it would be way faster cuz if
everyone had self-driving cars there
wouldn't be congestion and traffic like
that oh just be like so I like trains
but not Americans American trains or
American people people oh I like trains
but I don't think I can deal with the
train system nobody respects the Train
either they just treat it like it's a
[ __ ] public bathroom disgusting dude
I don't want to sit down I don't want to
sit down on the seat yeah disgusting cuz
I've been on a Chinese train and I've
been on a hunk no no
Taiwan train I went on a Japanese train
and I think I only like Japanese trains
the tunnel entrees are nice though yeah
they're nice maybe it's just hot yeah
because everyone stank I went on an
Amsterdam
that was pretty good you're the European
trainer you know I was on a French chain
and there was a crazy homeless man
yelling at everybody
oh and in this one we're perverts
tearing down Christina's chest I got him
on my blog he was just trying to x-ray
vision through her boobs and [ __ ]
Oh in Japan there was the guy that was
recording Jun oh wait were you guys
there yeah that was us so we were we
were in the Train there's his Japanese
dude saw Jude because she was wearing
like she wasn't wearing anything
scantily clad was like a spaghetti strap
yeah [ __ ] and then he just went nice and
then comes out he goes how's it going
how you doing you recorded my wife Ben
dad was like pissed yeah of course I was
laughing though because of how hard it
was because he's already action was so
big like if you liked it he could the
cartoonish he went was that in the Train
[Laughter]
there were no women showing their
shoulders yes it's too sick I
[ __ ] saw collarbone and he was
horny disgusting
[Music]